this morning the radio delivered the
warring message illegal fishing lines
have been found inside the Coco's
National Park by the Coast Guard the
National Geographic team springs into
action okay I can only hope that the
fishing lines are empty by my hopes were
not fulfilled a yellowfin tuna caught on
the line still life is released by Park
Rangers but the fight against the steel
and monofilament exhausted the tuna
which sank into the deep blue
every year hundreds of miles of illegal
fishing lines and thousands of folks are
confiscated inside the protected area a
little web that threatens the very
survival of marine life in the park one
of the last large ocean sanctuaries is
in danger
we got a call from the Coast Guard and
we jumped in to see the last catch
a green turtle fighting desperately for
her life
our team removed the hoop from her mouth
and she dives fast into the safety of
the deep but the ocean is not deep
enough and there are many more pilots
than heroes
you